[موسيقى]
في ضواحي جزيرة ستوكهولم ، أحدثت شركة
ناشئة أمواجًا في صناعة القوارب من
خلال عدم إحداث أي موجات على
الإطلاق نظرًا لعدم قيامنا بأي استيقاظ ، يمكننا
تشغيل القوارب بشكل أسرع بكثير
، الرجل المسؤول هو غوستاف
هاسيلسكوج 50  كان يبلغ من العمر عامًا يقود قاربًا يعمل بالغاز
لعقود من الزمان ، مما أدى إلى تسجيل بصمة كربونية خطيرة
في هذه العملية ، أدركت أن
هذا القارب يستهلك وقودًا أكثر بـ 15 مرة
من سيارتنا
، ولهذا السبب قرر في عام 2014 بناء قارب صديق
للبيئة وأسس شركته الناشئة
candela i  لم يكن لدي أي سجل حافل
كرائد أعمال لم يكن لدي أي
سجل حافل كأي
شخص يعمل مع القوارب قبل
أن يحصل على درجة الماجستير في الهندسة الميكانيكية على
الرغم من أنه تعلم عن
تقنية عمرها قرن من الزمان
تعطي أجنحة للقوارب تُعرف باسم القوارب المائية.
يمكن الآن استخدام
نفس التقنية التي تستخدمها في الطائرات بدون طيار
لتثبيت القارب ، حيث
يقوم زوج من القوارب المائية التي يتم التحكم فيها بواسطة الكمبيوتر
برفع القارب من الماء وإجراء
تعديلات دقيقة لأكثر من مائة مرة في
الثانية  هذا يخلق رحلة سلسة بسرعات قصوى
تبلغ حوالي 55 كيلومترًا في الساعة
يقول hasselskog أن
المحرك الكهربائي لا يصدر أي
انبعاثات ولا ضوضاء ، لذا فهو
أفضل للحياة البحرية أيضًا
حتى مع ما يقرب من 320 ألف
دولار من العملاء الذين يبدو أنهم على استعداد
لدفع ثمن رحلة أنظف
حصلت C8 على أكثر من مائة طلب في
غضون ستة أشهر من إطلاق كانديلا ،
وتقول إن كانديلا قد أطلق عليها اسم
تسلا البحار ، كما تعلم أنها
تحدث ثورة في صناعة السيارات الكهربائية ،
هل ترى أن
كانديلا يحتمل أن يكون لها نفس
النوع من التأثير في القوارب
لقد وجدنا الكثير من الإلهام في
تسلا على ما أعتقد ، ولكن عندما بدأت كانديلا ،
كان أكثر أنواع السيارات الكهربائية سخونة
في ذلك الوقت هو tiota prius
وما فعلته تسلا هو
إضافة الكثير من الأناقة إلى السيارات الكهربائية
كانديلا ليس  الشركة الناشئة الوحيدة التي تتطلع
إلى محاكاة نجاح تسلا على الماء
x-shore ، وهي شركة ناشئة سويدية ، وهي سفينة أرك
التي أنشأها موظفون سابقون في سبيس إكس ،
تعمل على تطوير منتجات عالية الجودة.
تعمل القوارب التي تعمل بالبطاريات في
حين أن المراكب المائية النقية المدعومة من شركة جنرال موتورز
تصنع قوارب كهربائية بالإضافة إلى
محركات خارجية لتثبيتها على السفن الموجودة ،
لكن إضافة القوارب المائية تمنح
Candela ميزة على منافسيها الذين يعملون بالبطارية
، كما تقول عن طريق الانزلاق فوق
الأمواج بدلاً من الدفع من خلالها
يستخدم قارب كانديلا طاقة أقل ، لذلك يمكن أن
تسير بشكل أسرع وتستمر لفترة أطول على بطارية أصغر ،
لكن القوارب الترفيهية وحدها
لن تحرك الإبرة في انبعاثات النقل البحري
يقول خبراء إن
السفن تنبعث منها حوالي مليار طن من
ثاني أكسيد الكربون كل عام عندما نتحدث
عن الشحن العالمي  سيكون
أكبر ثلاثة منتجين هم
سفن الحاويات أه البضائع السائبة
، ومن ثم تكون السفن الشخصية للناقلات
عادة الأصغر بالنسبة
للقوارب الترفيهية hasselskog هي البداية فقط
وهو الآن يطور عبّارات المدينة التي
تشبه تقريبًا طائرة مرور حيث
لديك سفينة كبيرة  الرياح في الأمام
وصغيرة في الخلف في
ستوكهولم ستجرب نموذج كانديلا الذي يتسع لـ 30 مقعدًا
لطرق الركاب في 202  3 يقول
أن لدينا ريف أرخبيل
يعتمد على هذا النوع من النقل
ونحتاج إلى إيجاد حلول صديقة للبيئة
ولكن أيضًا حلول أسرع
لأن القارب لا يخلق إيقاظًا
يمكنه المرور بشكل أسرع عبر الممرات المائية في المدينة
يقول hasselskog إنه يأمل في الحصول على هذه المكافأة
سيجعل المزيد من الأشخاص على متن القارب مع
مهمة القوارب الأكثر مراعاة للبيئة ،
وقد يكون لذلك تأثير غير مباشر على
قطاع الشحن الأوسع نطاقاً ، ويقول خبراء صناعة الشحن إنه
يتعين عليك التفكير في ما يتعرض
له الجمهور في كثير من الأحيان ، وعادةً ما تكون
هذه الحرفة الصغيرة وبناء
الثقة  في هذه العوالم المصغرة الأصغر
، ستزيد من الوعي التكنولوجي
للنطاق الأكبر ، تقوم
Hazelskog بتوسيع
مرافق Candela هذا العام لوضع المزيد من القوارب
على
الماء وترك مستقبل أنظف للشحن
في أعقابها